What does everybody have but most people dread?
Small talk. You're probably here because you
want to get better at small talk and you're in the
right place because my name is Chad and my partner
in crime and I wrote a book called Ask Powerful
Questions Create Conversations That Matter.
And it's been at the time of recording. It's
been sitting as a number one bestseller on
Amazon for several years. And I love hearing
from people who it's helped make conversations
go beyond small talk to conversations
that really matter. And so, in this video,
I'm going to share if you were to pick out only
one really key strategy to have better small talk.
I'm going to share that with you in this video.
Let's not waste any time. Let's get into it.
So, the tool that I'm going to share with you
I like to call the Awkward Elevator tool. And
the reason I call it that is that's the situation
that is typically associated with the most extreme
painful small talk. You're in an elevator, you've
got nothing else to talk about except what's
in that elevator and even imagine that there's
strangers in there. Now, granted, most of the time
you don't actually spark conversation with those
people. But if you had to, this tool would get you
out of that rut. But it also is remarkably useful
if you're at a networking meeting or you're at a
work Christmas party or boss said you need to go
team build and you're stuck in some capacity with
your colleagues. This tool will help you have more
meaningful conversations in all of those contexts.
And before I just drop the tool on you, you
have to unpack why have more conversations. So,
let me just get super nerdy for a minute and
read you 2 sentences from the book that really
stuck out to me when I was actually writing in
this section of the book and doing the research
on the science of asking really great questions
and creating conversations that matter. So,
the American Psychological Association did
a study on over 20,000 audio recordings of
people's conversation in everyday life. And what
they found was that people who had more authentic,
substantive conversations also tended
to be happier. Which I love because I
think that sometimes we think about creating
conversations that matter as important to not
have awkward conversation. And that's great. And
I think that creating conversations that matter
isn't just fun. It's actually essential to our
health and well-being. So, this awkward elevator
tool very simply is comes in chapter 2 of the
book. In the book, we unpack this layer and 5
different mindsets and tools to be able to ask
better questions and create conversations that
matter. I'm going to share number two with you.
And it's this idea of rapport which we define as
a relationship of trust. So, ideally, small talk
is intended to establish a relationship a trust.
And so, the tool that we share is to
follow your own natural genuine curiosity
based on what someone is wearing,
carrying, sharing, or presenting.
How did we come up with those? So, a quick rewind.
Will and I created and taught this tool to people
working for an organization that where we
were training facilitators to walk into a
room full of strangers and have meaningful
conversations about difficult topics. So,
they had no other context, there was nothing else
to ask about other than what they walked in the
room with. And what we found is that even though
you think the conversation starts with words,
the conversation started long before that
with what people brought into the room with
them.The conversation was started based on what
they're sharing, based on what they're wearing,
based on the jewelry that they have on, right?
This means something. It has a story behind it
based on people's emotion, based on what they're
actually carrying with them into the room,
based on how clean or dirty their shoes are
might mean they've been adventuring or they
have been cleaning their shoe, right? There's
all of this data that's actually shared with us
before the conversation's even begun. So, even
though you think you have to start a conversation
from scratch, there's actually a whole bunch of
stuff already on the table. And so, the tool is
look, right? Notice, be curious, and
inquire. Ask a question rooted in your
natural genuine curiosity based on what someone
is wearing, carrying, sharing, or presenting.
And the reason this tool is so incredibly
impactful is that when you talk to people,
typically they know that they were going to be
out in public today. And so, as human beings,
we choose what we put on our bodies and bring with
us to represent a little part of who we are. And
so, it's a very safe way to skip past some of the
like questions that people get very tired of which
is where are you from, which usually ends with
like you doing some weird geography game and then
conversation done. Or what do you do and
they answer that question and you're like,
"Not what I do", right? Conversation over. Those
are oftentimes conversation killers because people
have already had those dialogues so many times.
And so, even applying this tool though to what
someone is sharing is really useful. So, "Where
are you from?" -"Boston." Typically, we'd say,
"Oh, I have a cousin that lives in Boston."
Not useful for small talk, right? You think
it might be useful for small talk to jump in and
share a commonality. What is more useful is if
you follow your natural curiosity based on what
they've said and ask them a question. So, "Oh,
cool. Boston. What was it like growing up in
Boston? I grew up in the midwest." Do you see
how that had a little bit of self-disclosure but
also followed your curiosity? Just in case this
idea is not really sinking in, take this question
with you: "What are you curious about right now?"
As kids, we ask so many questions every
single day. And as adults, we've been trained
to speak in sentences that end in periods rather
than sentences that end in question marks. And
the best way to get better at small talk is to tap
into your curiosity. And curiosity is a choice by
the way. We can choose to turn up the dial and pay
attention to the things that are around us that a
person's wearing and follow that curiosity. This
tool can be misused. So, it's really important
to go back to the first level that we share in
this pyramid and then we call intention. So, your
intentions have to be other centered, right? You
can't make people the objects of your curiosity.
You've got to have the intention to really
connect with them and really hear a little bit
more about who they are. And that intention
of curiosity makes a really big difference
in the way that your conversations go. I hope this
was absolutely brilliant for you and that you take
this tool and practice it in your own world and
make conversations less awkward. We care about
these ideas enough so like yeah sure the books
available on Amazon. But you can also go to the
link below and download a free pdf of the book
that unpacks intention that tool that i just
shared as well. As I held up this giant question,
there is a deck of cards that i've created called
We! Connect Cards. And they're filled with
60 of the best questions to ask... To skip
past small talk and really create conversations
that matter. And so if any of that interests you,
check the links in the description to learn more.
I'm Chad. This was awesome. I had a blast hanging
out in cyber space with you. I hope that our
paths cross at some point in pixel land or real
life. Have an awesome day filled with zero small
talk. And if you want to go much deeper, these
2 videos will dive you further into this path
of creating conversations that matter. Cheers!